We're looking to see if music can change the world.
Grammy award-winning producer and film director Mark Johnson...
...has dedicated his life to connecting people through music.
He and his crew have recorded musicians around the world in their natural settings...
...and he has compiled these recordings into a top-selling CD and DVD.
Johnson recently finished his first concert tour of North America and Spain...
...featuring some of these performers.
One thing about, you know, making peace is that...
...it's not necessarily one day...
...where the whole world stops fighting.
It's more of a state of mind...
...and a consciousness of all the people here on the planet.
So, what I think music can do is it can go from one heart to another heart...
...and it can truly express the sentiment behind the words.
Johnson says that growing up in New York City helped shape his vision of helping humanity.
And as an interpersonal communications major at the University of New Hampshire,...
...he learned how people create meaning in the world.
Great music and art are moments in time.
They exist everywhere.
But in these,...
...you can harness the energy to actually inspire everybody to believe more in each other...
...and make a difference in a limited time we have in this world.